beth is on the line beth is in
washington d.c hi beth how can we help
hello i am 32 i started baby step 2
four years ago with and twenty six
thousand dollars in student loans
today i am proud to say i'm down to
eleven thousand
yay way to go yeah
thanks um but i've had to overcome some
pretty substantial setbacks and baby
step two
after i finished graduate school i
landed a job in my field of health care
and injury prevention
but i quickly found out i would always
have work but i won't always get paid
for it
i went to work every day for 19 months
not knowing if i was going to get laid
off
and i worked numerous side gigs to the
point that i was sleeping less than four
hours a night for many days a week
i started and stopped my baby step two
so many times
due to job insecurity and also having to
move a thousand miles for my current job
in bc
during baby step two i struggled with
anxiety depression
self-harm because i endlessly shame
myself for the financial mess
that i'm in and i feel so behind the
rest of my peers
i turn to dave's podcast for
encouragement which do help
but i have found that my mental health
issues can sometimes get worse because
so many people on the show are paying
off their debt in much less time
which makes me feel like even more of a
failure i've been living on scorched
earth
which has absolutely helped me pay down
debt but i feel like i'm also scorched
because
yeah my mental health and the problem
burnt the proverbial candle at both ends
kiddo
i mean you went beyond gazelle intense
you didn't even feed the gazelle while
he was running
but i i wholeheartedly agree and i'm one
of those people i'm an all or nothing
i can tell and i'm definitely i'm in
therapy and which has been a lifesaver
and i'm a huge advocate of therapy but
i'm just really curious if
others that have had an obstacle ridden
baby step two like myself if
they feel the same way and i kind of
feel like a lot of times i'm alone
no you're not just what happens
is this gazelle intense thing is so
weird
it's hard to get some people to turn it
on and it's so hard to get some people
turn it off
you know and so there's very few people
like that are like the perfectly middle
gazelles
some of them are like lazy fat gazelles
or some of them are starving the boy to
death and running him
haggard like you've been doing and
there's all kinds of internal
motivations in both cases or lack of
internal motivation
motivations in both cases i your journey
sounds a lot like mine beth
i went crazy then stopped and then gave
up and then started sprinting again
and then i realized i left my wife
behind and so i thought the wise thing
would be to drag her along and then we
both stopped then we started walking and
um then there became like dave said is
finding that balance
all depression anxiety all those are you
know this is they're just alarms
telling you that you're not whole and
that you are find yourself alone out on
an island
and you know those things right so yeah
i don't want you to feel alone for a
second in this journey because we hear
this stuff
all the time so john let me ask you
something because i uh
i'm gonna talk about beth right in front
of her here okay um
sure does it help because obviously
she's got great intellect
just listening to her how articulate she
is and apparently she wrote all that out
because i think she was reading it
does it help to digest it that way
because does it help her get on top of
it
to look down on that piece of paper and
see because you just self-analyzed the
whole thing beth while we were listening
to you
you didn't even like need us you'd
already bounce it off the ground and you
knew exactly what to do
from your intellect right but you can
intellect and data
can be just as addictive just as
distancing
as any number of other distancing
behaviors right
like drinking or running or
too much exercise or too much food you
can over intellectualize things and get
way away from it okay
it can be a separation mechanism okay um
beth why did you work for 19 months not
knowing whether you're gonna get paid or
not
you are too wise and too smart and too
gifted to put yourself in that situation
what was it about that
that season that that you put yourself
through that
i appreciate that question and i was
working for a hospital system in boston
and um unfortunately they just are not
one of the richest hospitals
and yeah so great mentors
yes you worked in the hospital i i
understand hospitals have
seasons every place has seasons where
they struggle
why did you choose to stay in that
ecosystem
i looked for 19 months for another job
with the support of my peers saying that
we're going to give you as much money as
we can as many hours as we can but
unfortunately this is our limit
and i applied for jobs for over a year
and i made it all the way to the very
end and there i learned the hard way in
2017 and 18
so many people are hiring from within
and i got all the way to the last thing
and
and basically they said sorry we took
someone else and
i think for me i kind of hit this rut of
i kept trying and trying and trying to
leave
but i had a paycheck from week to week
for a period of time and it was
stressful and that's why i picked up
side gigs so in the event i went to work
one day and lost my job
so you didn't go 19 months without pay
you went 19 months with insecurity about
whether the check was going to clear
that week
right correct oh okay so beth i want to
back up to the front of this call
you ever you ever have a friend that you
haven't seen them in a long time and you
see them
and you realize they've they've lost 50
or 60 pounds
and it's so incredible to see them and
they're excited and you're excited
but you get that burst of hooray and
they've been living it so long
you know it's they see the the
incremental changes in the mirror as
they go
when you first called and you said
you've been cranking on this deal for
four years you've paid off a hundred and
what is that
fifteen thousand dollars through
a graduate degree through insecure
paychecks and what did dave and i do we
cheered
as though we haven't seen you in years
and we are so ex
impressed with how far you've come
you've got to step back and use that
intellect get 30 000 feet
above this situation and go wow look at
me
really really proud of yourself you need
to look in the mirror and go wow girl
look at you
you have stumbled and tripped and
grinded
and that's not even a word you've ground
your way you have
dragged and pulled and sprinted and
you're almost there
and i hope you will take a moment and
celebrate you because you're kicking
butt man
yeah you really i mean the first
three minutes were touched down in the
super bowl
and the next several pages
read were all the things that are wrong
it is normal to overdo it
and so give yourself permission to let
off the gas a little bit you are
overdoing it
but you have done an incredible thing to
this point
you didn't do it wrong you just were a
little extreme
so back off a little bit get some sleep
eat
love the girl in the mirror she's a hero
this is the dave ramsey show